uh can we talk relationships for a
second we should let's talk
relationships so
um
i know you know how do you have a real
relation i don't know how do i have a
little there's about 15 minutes left so
you know let's um let's um let's get to
the heart of the matter so how do you
have a relationship like meaning
you know hey uh can't can't go on a date
gotta you know i'm at work right now you
know or you know hey can't have sex
honey i got a big day tomorrow how do
you how do you have a real relationship
i never had a relationship while i was
shooting scenes
the whole time i was with my husband i
wasn't shooting scenes and then when i
went back to shooting scenes i just had
a nice casual group of people in my life
that i would see and a nice roster of
guys that were hanging out with but they
all knew what i did you had a roster
just well yeah you know respect you know
there's so many guys out there that talk
about having a roster a hotation
buy that domain right now okay i'm a big
domain buyer so i haven't done it um and
i did just try to have my first non-porn
relationship post covid last year
um and it lasted for six months okay and
i knew him through other people so i
trusted him as a normal person he had no
problem with you know what i do the
skies will
the long the short of it is
i was suspect that something wasn't
right my best friend was suspect that
something wasn't right six months in i
find out he's got a live-in girlfriend
he's been with for 12 [ __ ] years
they're in an open relationship no they
are not an open relationship he was
lying to her
so um that's how i got the cartier watch
and the love bracelet
because i blackmailed him
um
i made him give me a large sum of cash
really and i went shopping with it and i
made him make a large donation to
planned parenthood good for you that is
the funniest thing i've never ever
heard now do you feel bad about that or
hell no [ __ ] no lisa here were his
choices i found his girls socials
and i was just yeah i just put on her
instead um i i just found out we share a
boyfriend
you said
you wrote on her page he steals her
phone
by the way what was she was she younger
she older did she do
um both foreign he has to marry jewish
with this girl but jewish guys oh yeah
you know
[Applause]
so guys it always happens to me this way
so yeah so and this was my first like
wait if you messaged her then what kind
of leverage did you have over he wanted
me to delete it he took her phone so she
thought she lost it for the period of
time oh my gosh
sweat it for 24 hours i mean everyone we
knew was calling like
giving these negotiation scenarios like
what's it gonna take for you to delete
that post and like you know i'm still
thinking about it like i still i want to
know what i want is a post or a message
just a post on her you know on her page
on her instagram like on a comment on a
picture comment can you imagine getting
not knowing anything dude lisa and
commented on my pictures
oh my so you know
i let i let him sweat it that whole
first night and then the next morning
with his business partner and everybody
i'm like all right listen this is how
much the business partner was weighing
in yeah because he was the one that
wanted to give me cash because he felt
that if i went public with this story it
would hurt their mutual businesses
together because i have such girl power
in new york city
and this would give me a bad look right
um and you know what uh i've kept a good
rapport with him because i got
everything i wanted out of it and i
still do get to eat for free at his
restaurant and every once in awhile i
want pizza from one of his restaurants
that's too far that delivered to my
place and i can put it in a [ __ ] uber
and have the food
there's no reason to lie to somebody for
six months
how do you get away with it now have you
ever went to justice
and you know what i see this was my
first civilian dating experience out of
porn after coving oh that's how we got
my girlfriends taught me after like
you've got to go to their place like
you've got to see how they live
for six months you didn't go to his
place no because you know what i love my
apartment
lisa you're brilliant you're smart
you're opinionated how the hell do you
not go there i don't want to honestly
sleep over and i don't want to leave in
the city at two o'clock in the morning
it's not safe like i was being lazy i
know this now
lisa you're my dream girl i was in my
comfort zone but like the red flags were
there but i wasn't paying attention and
we like would just lay on the couch
drink cocktails and watch chopped like
it was a great relationship to me with
your house at my house and he was busy
you were comfortable little did i know
he was busy in another relationship but
the funny thing was wow he has the least
amount of game of any guy i've ever
dated at least
when everyone found out that i was
dating him that we had kept it a secret
from all of our mutual friends like 30
people that know they're like what made
you choose him i'm like because
i just felt like he had no game and that
he would probably like never cheat on me
so
and they're like well do you think the
guys with
but if you had all these mutual friends
nobody told them
yeah i didn't tell any of them because i
didn't want things to be awkward
his place in six months what was he
thinking that you would never he never
even had to come up with an experience
no he knew yeah at the time
people say it was a ticking time bomb
for him he was just riding the ride it's
really good right lisa was he a wealthy
guy or a good looking guy wealthy good
looking um
a little bit of both very he's wealthy
successful but he's a worker he's not
like second generation money's first
generation money which is important but
i will say this when i went into cartier
with the cash it was the best experience
ever because we told everybody at
cartier actually one of his partners
took me
um we go in and i'm like now this county
experience we dump out these duffel bags
of cash
and they're sitting there with their
masks on and their gloves and i'm just
like videoing this they're all just
counting i'm like so here's how this
goes down like a mafia boss right yeah
and now i'm on the come up okay it was a
great come up when is the movie being
written about your life that's what i
want to know i just see her with her
little journal interviewing played by
jayla
[Music]
you